The Nobel Prizes are handed
out to humanity's best
and brightest, but sometimes
even the best and brightest
get overlooked.
Howdy folks.
Trace here wrapping up
the coverage for DNews.
The Nobel Prizes were
announced over the last week,
and there were a couple
of surprises out there.
The prizes come in six
categories, chemistry,
economics, literature,
medicine, peace and physics.
This year, three scientists
shared the chemistry prize
for creating computer
models of molecules
so we don't have to use these
peg and ball ones anymore.
Canadian author, Alice Munro,
took the literature award home,
three Americans won the
Nobel Prize in medicine
for discovering how cells
transport things around.
They're like little factories.
The Organization for the
Prohibition of Chemical Weapons
was awarded the
Nobel Peace Prize,
and the prize for physics
went to two scientists who
discovered the Higgs
boson particle.
Economics doesn't get
handed out until Monday.
Kind of an incredible
list, don't you think?
But what about the
amazing projects
that didn't warrant a Nobel win?
The Nobel Prize for peace
is pretty existential.
How do people encourage
peace globally?
Removing chemical
weapons is a great one,
but what about
promoting non-violence
in the face of a much
more powerful aggressor?
Mahatma Gandhi promoted a
free and independent India
and was assassinated in 1948.
Though his efforts helped
the Britons to quit India,
he never won a Nobel
Prize for peace.
Though he was
nominated posthumously.
I think we all agree the idea
that DNA and genes passed
from parents to offspring is
pretty much a game changer,
but the scientists credited
for the discovery never
won the Nobel Prize for
physiology and medicine.
In the 1940s, Oswald
Avery discovered
it wasn't a protein which
passed your hereditary traits
to your children,
but DNA itself.
Which might seem kind
of like, oh, duh now.
But then, it was revolutionary,
because most scientists
thought the opposite.
The Human Genome
Project might be
one of the most interesting
and wonderful things
to happen with the human
DNA since it was discovered.
And since that project
was completed in 2003,
we've been learning
things about humans
we may never have
discovered without it.
We've catalogued all the DNA
of the whole human, and still
no Nobel Prize.
There are so many more
of these, you guys.
The Nobel Prize for
chemistry was never
given to Dmitri
Mendeleev for creating
the modern periodic table.
The inventor of radio
telecommunications,
Nikola Tesla, never received
a prize for physics.
Robert Noyce, the
inventor of the microchip,
never got a prize.
Fred Hoyle, who coined
the term the Big Bang,
claimed new elements were made
inside stars during fusion,
never got a Nobel
Prize for that.
Leo Tolstoy, one of the most
critically acclaimed novelist
in human history, no Nobel medal
we're hanging around his neck.
We could talk
about this all day.
There are only so
many Nobel prizes.
And unfortunately for
some, once in awhile
you've got this great season
and it's hard to pick.
And other times
it's pretty sparse.
I mean, personally, I'd love
to see Malala Yousafzai win
for her work toward peace.
The Taliban shot her
in the head for simply
trying to go to school.
Education, it's important.
She stood up to them
peacefully, survived,
and is still working
for peace today.
I think the Nobel Prizes
are an incredible way
to show recognition for
humanity's best achievements.
But how do you feel about it?
Share your own opinions in
the comments below the video,
and thanks a lot for
watching DNews today.
Take a second and
like us on Facebook,
and we hope you come back soon.